♫ Yo, we back in this one now
♫ Yeah, and we got your
ticket to the sickest club
♫ So many ladies havin' a good time
♫ We got the secret to getting
girls in the line outside
♫ See those smiles those
girls in the club is happy
♫ They got all that they want being shaggy
♫ Like what they look at that stripe
♫ They go crazy when they see
a straight show in their butt
♫ 'Cause this ain't no ordinary club y'all
♫ We got the secret to
keeping girls partying
♫ Naw, it ain't the sickest deejay
♫ And our drink specials are really bad
♫ And there ain't no
good-looking men here, but
♫ We got puppies in this club
♫ We got puppies, we got puppies
♫ We got mother doggin' puppies
♫ We got puppies in this club
♫ We got puppies, we got puppies
♫ Make it Wayne Campbell,
or they're barking for days
♫ Peas, chicken and rice, low sodium glaze
♫ That's why she's got you now
♫ 'Cause she'll give you those eyes
♫ Straight up on your thighs
for peas, chicken and rice
♫ Puppies here, puppies there
♫ Puppies all over the club
♫ Watch 'em Ned, watch 'em dance
♫ Hold them Nevin while you dance
♫ Play with two, play with three
♫ Shove that vodka cranberry
♫ We got puppies in this club
♫ Puh-puh-puppies in this club
♫ This the best
♫ I love puppies
♫ I think puppies are so lovely
♫ When they hug me, rub up on me
♫ Got me laughing, sometimes clapping
♫ Puppies jump up on my lapping
♫ Get to lapping on me yappin at me
♫ And in when they nappin' on me
♫ Hahaha, you've never seen girls
♫ Having this much fun at the club
♫ Women literally love
dogs more than people
♫ I know that's true
♫ Why do you think that is
♫ 'Cause dogs show unconditional affection
♫ Yeah, and they cute
♫ We got puppies in this club
♫ We got puppies, we got puppies
♫ We got mother doggin' puppies
♫ We got puppies in this club
♫ We got puppies, we got puppies
♫ We got puppies in this club ♫
- This is my favorite club!
♫ Are you elite, think puppies
ain't enough at your feet
♫ Well, hang right through this piece
♫ But please keep it discreet
♫ 'Cause puppies out
there but the rest in here
♫ Full of dogs and look
cats, kittens, and piggies
♫ Cats, kittens, and piggies
♫ Full of dogs and look,
cats, kittens, and piggies
♫ We got puppies in this club
♫ Cats, kittens, and piggies
♫ Full of dogs, full of kitties
♫ Aw damn, feels like it's
getting way out of hand
♫ This business isn't working
♫ Out quite as we planned
♫ So many animals,
there's no place to stand
♫ Got a surplus inventory
compared to demand
♫ Aw, we made a mistake with this one
♫ Yeah, but we gonna keep this club open
♫ For at least another 30 minutes
♫ Yeah, so grab a drink, grab an animal
♫ Maybe take it home
♫ Yeah we don't have
homes for these animals
♫ We got puppies in this club
♫ Cats, kittens, and piggies
♫ Full of dogs, full of kitties
♫ We got puppies in this club
♫ We got puppies
♫ We got puppies in this club ♫
- Yo, seriously y'all, ya gotta
take some of these dogs home.
(cats meowing)
- Yeah, Yeah.
- Man, I don't know why
we thought about pigs.
(pigs squealing)